hey guys it is the fifth of April today
my name is Jess McDonald and you are
watching games but news first up Bill
Gates has said he'd be all foreign Xbox
business spinoff if the idea was
proposed dates told the Fox Business
Network reporter that he'd absolutely
support the move though it's worth
saying that Microsoft have said that
they've never had plans to sell off Xbox
at the same time some major shareholders
including Microsoft co-founder paul
allen's investment group have urged the
company to spin off the game unit which
doesn't necessarily mean selling and
focus on corporate customers instead
gates followed up his comments by saying
that he thinks the Xbox business is
integral to Microsoft's long-term
strategy and that the Xbox one has
helped bridge the gap between PC and
console gaming in other xboxing news
Phil Spencer has released a bunch of
details and teasers as to what we can
expect from Microsoft at e3 this year
the xbox had said that new IP and new
sequels will make an appearance on top
of that he said that the company will be
focusing on hardcore gamers are planning
on releasing information about external
story support for Xbox one are close to
finalizing a date for minecraft on xbox
one and that may is going to be a big
month for announcements as well let me
know what you want microsoft to deliver
at e3 this year by web writer david
guetta took to tumblr to discuss how
difficult it is to cut content from
games he said that in regard to Dragon
Age Inquisition the temp has to be more
focused on making sure everything the
game already has works properly rather
than adding anything new the game is
approaching alpha which is also known as
the content complete stage where the
biggest cuts occur Gator has said every
cut feels like it's reducing the overall
quality of the game until there are so
many of them you feel like you're
producing a piece of crap until you
remind yourself that every game goes
through this and the alternative is
shipping late or not at all call of duty
details have started to land with full
force as we get a better idea of what to
expect from advanced warfare the slew of
details can be found in their entirety
on gamespot but some of the more
interesting ones include the utilization
of a new game engine which is currently
unspecified a story opening of a
catastrophic events at the devil
likening to a global 911 assessing of
the year 2050 for a single protagonist
the incorporation of some kind of co-op
energy guns that don't use traditional
ammunition and so many other things let
me know if you're excited for Call of
Duty advanced warfare or if you're over
the series in that commenting section
below that's all the things i have to
tell you for your monday but be sure to
join me again same time tomorrow where
we're expecting a bunch more news